la surveillance syndromique la
surveillance en population nous permet
de construire cette fameuse première
carte vous le savez l'immense majorité
des cas sont bénins et sont pris en
charge en ville par les médecins
généralistes les médecins traitants mais
aussi par exemple par les laboratoires
hier par exemple elle souhaite médecin a
réalisé 2 195 intervention pour une
suspicion de kobe de 19 au cours de la
journée soit 6 % de l'activité totale
elle souhaite médecin les services
d'urgence ont enseigné 1200 passage hier
soit 5 % de leur activité pour une
suspicion d'infection coronavirus et ça
a conduit à 36% d'hospitalisation dont
trois pour cent en réanimation enfin
vous savez que nous surveillons aussi
l'activité des laboratoires et le taux
de positivité des tests réalisés ce taux
de positivité était hier de 18% pour
toute la france
vous voyez donc cette première carte
cette circulation active du virus
cette carte illustre la notion d'
activité épidémique de situation
épidémiologique de la maladie qu vide
elle est construite à partir de données
qui reflète le nombre de personnes a
dressé dans les services d'urgences par
leur médecin traitant par leurs médecins
de ville pour une suspicion d'infection
kobe de 19 par rapport au nombre total
de passages aux urgences quelle que soit
la cause ces données sont issues d'un
système de recueil de données publiées
quotidiennement sur le site data.gouv.fr
est évidemment accessibles au public
elles sont issues du réseau de presque
700 service d'accueil des urgences et
permettent de comptabiliser plus de 90%
des passages aux urgences
en france elle représente donc une
source d'information qui est affiché
département par département et reflète
donc la circulation circulation virale
ou la situation épidémique dans un
territoire
il nous permet donc d'utiliser par
ailleurs des moyennes des moyennes sur
les sept derniers jours
et c'est ainsi que nous avons ce fameux
code couleur déterminer selon des seuils
en verre dans la totalité des passages
aux urgences observé
il y a moins de 6 % des patients
qui viennent pour une suspicion
d'infection coville en orange
cette proportion varie entre 6 et 10% de
l'ensemble des passages et en rouge plus
de 10% des patients qui se présentent
aux urgences viennent pour un motif de
suspicion d'infection coronavirus ce
sont ces seuils qui définissent les
couleurs affichées sur la carte et qui
permettent de visualiser un reflet de la
situation épidémique de la circulation
virale dans le département ces données
ont l'avantagé d'être relativement
précoce sensibles c'est à dire qu elles
évolueront rapidement en cas d'évolution
dans un sens ou dans un autre de
l'épidémie elles ont donc été choisis
pour nous permettre de réagir le plus
rapidement possible en synthèse santé
publique france a procédé au
reclassement sur la carte de ce soir que
vous voyez actuellement de neuf
départements les données prenait en
effet en compte de nombreuses campagnes
de dépistage en cours et l'on peut s'en
féliciter
les dépistages relatifs aux ehpad et des
dépistages de professionnels de santé
ainsi le reclassement du dispositif au
secours de re de recours aux eaux
services d'urgence permet le
reclassement du département de l'aisne
du rouge à l'orangé avec sur la synthèse
un maintien de la couleur rouge puisque
le système hospitalier de ce département
est en forte tension pour le calvados le
reclassement est de la couleur orange la
couleur verte et la carte de synthèse
indiquera à la couleur verte
pour le cher leur classement met du
rouge au vert avec une synthèse orange
puisque l'hospitalisation est en tension
pour la dordogne on bascule de l'oranje
au vert avec un code synthétique vert
pour la haute corse
on passe du rouge au vert pour le lot du
rouge au vert pour le lièvre pour la
nièvre pardon du rouge au vert pour
l'oise c'est une discussion là aussi
avec les acteurs de terrain
on passe du vert à l'orangé mais vous
savez que dans l'oise où il ya eu
d'importants cas groupés
le système hospitalier est toujours sous
tension est donc l'indicateur général
restera rouge
enfin pour le tarn le reclassement et de
l'oranje au vert les données utilisées
sont aussi publiées quotidiennement sur
le site data.gouv.fr je vous le disais
sont enrichis par des données locale
d'activité de sos médecins de ressenti
des médecins généralistes d'activité des
laboratoires de présence ou non de
d'investigation en cours de cas groupés
est donc ce sont grâce aux échanges que
nous avons entre santé publique france
et les agences régionales de santé que
ces données seront réglés régulièrement
actualisés
les données sont affichés donc sous
forme de cartes avec des moyennes sur
les sept derniers jours et données
hospitalières nous permettent de
construire la deuxième carte
ce soir nous avons des données qui sont
issus de 1364 établissements 25 1887
personnes sont toujours hospitalisés
pour une infection kovy de 19 ce solde
est négatif de 396 malade donc une bonne
nouvelle mais nous avons encore six cent
soixante huit nouvelles admissions à
l'hôpital de patients atteints
d'infections pour un navire russe
le nombre maximum avait été atteint je
vous le rappelle le 14 avril avec 32
mille 250 malades atteints de colite 19
et hospitalisé en même temps 7183
patients sont toujours hospitalisés en
réanimation dont 3878 atteint de kovy 19
ce chiffre est en baisse le nombre
maximum de patients atteints
d'infections coronavirus ce que 8,19 en
réanimation avait presque atteint 7200
le 9 avril quatre régions concentrent 76
% des hospitalisations en réanimation
il s'agit de l'île de france de grand
test d'auvergne rhône-alpes et des hauts
de france au cours des dernières 24
heures 73 nouveaux patients dans un état
grave ont été admis en réanimation en
tenant compte des sorties qui sont
nombreuses nous avons 141 patients en
moins en service de réanimation ce
besoin de baisse lentement mais
régulièrement et vous savez que c'est un
indic
tort évidemment important de tensions
hospitalières et de mobilisation de
toutes les énergies et de toutes les
compétences de nos professionnels de
santé dans les outre mer on relève 72
hospitalisations dont 20 patients en
réanimation au total et c'est un chiffre
important à souligner plus de cinquante
mille deux cents personnes sont sortis
guéris de l'hôpital auquel il faut
ajouter les dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui n'ont pas eu recours à
l'hôpital et qui ont évolué
favorablement à la maison cette épidémie
est massive cette épidémie est sévère
92000 87 personnes infectées par
coronavirus ont été hospitalisés depuis
le 1er mars dont près de 16 mille deux
cents en réanimation
la circulation du virus vous le
constatez restent encore à un niveau
élevé
nous devons donc tous respecter les
gestes barrière qui doivent devenir des
réflexes vous voyez maintenant la carte
des tensions hospitalières sur les
capacités de réanimation cette carte
présente le niveau de saturation de nos
services de réanimation
en france c'est à dire le nombre de lits
de réanimation qui sont occupés par des
patients dans un état grave
infectés par kobe de 19 par rapport au
nombre total de lits de réanimation à
l'état initial sur le territoire
national ces données sont donc le reflet
de la saturation du système sanitaire et
surtout delà de notre capacité de
réanimation et de notre capacité encore
à prendre en charge d'éventuels nouveaux
patients de réanimation qu'il soit
atteint ou non d'infection covit 19
il est important de comprendre que les
tensions en réanimation du fait de
l'épidémie en cours restent dans
certains territoires très importante
compte tenu de l'afflux majeur de
patients graves dans les rets nimation
de nos hôpitaux
ces dernières semaines avec la vague
d'infections comité neuf mais aussi avec
la vague des patients graves qui ont
potentiellement été pendant le
confinement à distance du système de
froid l'approchent régional et cohérente
pour les hôpitaux les seuils que nous
utilisons dans cette deuxième carte sont
les suivants envers le taux d'occupation
des lits de réanimation par des patients
graves atteints de colite 19
être inférieur à 60% dans ce cas
l'indicateur est vert si le niveau
d'occupation des lits de réanimation par
des patients atteints de kobe 19 et
entre 60 et 80%
nous affichons une couleur orange et si
le seuil est supérieur à 80 % ce qui est
vraiment exceptionnel
la tension est alors majeure et le seuil
est indiquée en couleur rouge
ces seuils permettent donc de définir
très clairement les couleurs que nous
utilisons sur la deuxième carte et nous
permettent vous le voyez de refléter de
déterminer la possibilité d'accueillir
de nouveaux patients en service de
réanimation
nous observons avec beaucoup d'attention
comme chaque jour la situation dans les
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
7176 établissements dont 4545 ehpad ont
signalé un épisode que 8,19 à santé
publique france les signalements font
remonter 30 2007 191 cas confirmés par
test pcr depuis le 1er mars
en ce qui concerne la mortalité la
mortalité hospitalière depuis le 1er
mars nous déplorons quinze mille trois
cent soixante neuf décès 80 2% des décès
sont survenus chez des personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans avec 40 décès en
outre-mer 17 en guadeloupe 14 en
martinique 8 à mayotte et en guyane
et puis vous savez que nous observons
aussi la mortalité en ehpad et au sein
des établissements médico-sociaux et
nous déplorons 9225 décès survenus au
sein de ces établissements depuis le
début de l'épidémie
en additionnant les décès survenus à
l'hôpital et en institution
nous déplorons 24 1594 décès depuis le
1er mars selon les estimations de santé
publique france il y aurait eu en france
130 1185 cas confirmés les deux
premières cartes que vous avez vu nous
permettent d'élaborer la carte de
synthèse de la situation épidémique que
vous voyez désormais en ce moment le
ministre olivier ferrand a déjà expliqué
le raisonnement pour rappel cette carte
comportera trois seuils
pour bien montrer l'évolution
différentiel de l'épidémie en fonction
des territoires et expliquer la façon de
procéder lorsque le territoire et à
anvers elle démontre que les deux
paramètres précédents sont en dessous
des seuils ces paramètres de circulation
virale de situation épidémique
le paramètre de tensions hospitalières
en orange et territoires pour lesquels
un ou deux paramètres sont au niveau des
seuils intermédiaires et en rouge les
territoires dans lesquels un paramètre
au moins est au dessus des seuils
définis
certains départements continuent à être
classées en rouge ou en orange sur notre
carte de synthèse alors que l'activité
épidémique y est faible cela est lié au
fait que nous privilégions une approche
régionale concernant l'offre de soins
critiques
ainsi les départements appartenant à une
région où les tensions dans l'offre de
soins et notamment en réanimation
restent importantes sont aujourd'hui
classées en rouge car ce critère est
fondamentale puisque le déconfinement ne
peut se faire dans des bonnes conditions
que si le système de santé et tout
particulièrement les professionnels de
santé sont capables de faire fonctionner
les services dans des conditions proches
de la normale
cette carte a pour objectif d'illustrer
la méthode de travail elle donne une
indication à un instant t donc
aujourd'hui 1er mai de la situation dans
chaque territoire cette carte n'est pas
figée elle va évoluer et il va s'adapter
à l'évolution de la situation
c'est une photographie d'une situation
qui reste voulu observer ce soir très
évolutive je vous remercie